Fox News hilariously and tragically made
a false report of the death of Supreme
Court Justice Ruth Bader Ginsburg
yesterday of course she's 85 she's been
recovering from surgery to remove
cancerous nodules from a lung and she's
had her fair share of health issues over
the years Donald Trump's favorite show
Fox & Friends was the place where this
happened and imagine what people thought
when this image came up of Ruth Bader
Ginsburg in 1933 to 2019 on the screen
identical to those images you see on
television networks when famous people
pass away they mistakenly put it up on
screen when trying to go to yet another
segment on the horrible things that are
happening on college campuses it's just
everything everything about this it's
perfect they want to do a segment about
how horrible college campuses have
become and they incorrectly put up an
image claiming that Ruth Bader Ginsburg
has passed away they ended up doing an
apology for it here it is and very very
awkward on set as they apologize for
this error that's right in the meantime
we need to apologize at the beginning of
Ainsley's interview with the professor a
technical error in the control room
triggered a graphic of Ruth Bader
Ginsburg with a date on it she we don't
want to make it seem anything other that
that was a mistake that was an accident
we believe she is still at home
recovering from surgery yes indeed all
right meanwhile it's certainly yeah
Steve Doocy sounding super super sincere
credible and alpha there during that
explanation right so clearly they had
the image ready they're ready and
waiting to put it up on screen at a
moment's notice and what wasn't a
mistake is that someone was told to make
the graphic and there's people who are
defending this by saying David it's
logical that they would have this image
and dozens or even hundreds of others
four famous people who are getting up
there in age but what doesn't make as
much sense is that before a graphic like
this would be sort of filed in a in a
way we're with a single click it would
just go out live to air means that it
has to have been approved by
multiple producers that this is the
image that they would be using when that
horrible day sometimes comes in the
future so it makes sense that they'd
have the image but it makes a little bit
less sense to me that it could be
accidentally triggered to end up live on
air in this way but the continuing saga
of technical errors on fox news
imagine we know Donald Trump loves Fox
and Friends imagine Donald Trump
yesterday morning sitting there in the
residence at the White House or in the
Oval Office or just in some room or
there's a TV on in the background and
he's watching that instead of listening
to his presidential daily briefing or
whatever he does
imagine that image coming up and at
least for a fraction of a second
president Donald Trump thinking that
Ruth Bader Ginsburg has passed away and
he's going to get a chance to put
another Supreme Court justice on the
court not for now Donald not today and I
think that that's good news for
everybody